one of Facebook's early investors and a
former mentor to CEO Mark Zuckerberg
warns of the social media Giants harmful
and potentially irreversible effects on
society
Roger McNamee makes the case in a new
Washington Monthly essay called how to
fix Facebook before it fixes us he
argues Facebook has prioritized
advertisers and not protected users
McNamee writes we are drowning in
evidence that there are costs that
society may not be able to afford in a
new year's pledge Zuckerberg admits
Facebook has a lot of work to do this
year he vows to take action against
offensive content and Falls news
articles that could reach the site's
more than two billion monthly active
users the author of the essay now joins
us roger McNamee is managing director of
the private equity firm elevation
partners he still holds a stake in
Facebook welcome thank you it's a
pleasure to be here you describe
yourself as a mentor to Zuckerberg but
then why are you worried now what so
it's one of these really sad things I
feel like Jimmy Stewart character in an
Alfred Hitchcock movie I spent years
helping to build this company when I
first met mark they were having an
existential crisis I was asked by one of
his colleagues to go in and meet with
the boss he couldn't tell me why it was
a big secret I said sit down with him
I'm closer to him that I am to you and I
say mark if it hasn't already happened
member the company's two years old he's
22
see mark if it hasn't already happened
Facebook or Microsoft are sorry
Microsoft or Yahoo is gonna try to buy
you they're gonna offer a billion
dollars everybody's gonna tell you to
take it I'm telling you you have one of
the greatest opportunities I've ever
seen don't take the money build the
company that began a four-year period
where I talked to him almost every no
certainly every week sometimes every day
I then you know he outgrew me and so
company goes on it becomes massively
successful I'm a huge fan I'm sitting in
the front row and I'm thinking wow this
is the greatest thing I ever did then
right at the beginning of the
presidential election campaign in 2016 I
see things going wrong and it makes me
very concerned and eventually in October
I go to them and I say you know I think
we have a structural problem here and
they treat it like a PR crisis rather
than like a business what was the
structure what did you see
well initially I saw I saw people
manipulating essentially bad actors
manipulating Facebook to harm people who
are powerless and its political ads
popping up on your own Facebook I saw a
political ads but I also saw people
scraping Facebook and then about black
lives matter and selling it to police
departments I saw financial institutions
using Facebook tools to discriminate in
housing
it was a wide range of things basically
Facebook created tools for engagement
and in order to get people engaged they
use things that effectively addicted
them and so people lost the power to
really discern what they were reading
and it became very hard to get what they
call it filter bubbles that people get
trapped in this place where they think
everyone agrees them because Facebook
only shows you stuff they think you want
so is it painful for you to speak out
this way against a company that you were
an early investor and still owns taken
oh it's unbelievably painful in fact
what I really want to do is be able to
sit down with mark and Cheryl and go
guys this is a situation where you need
to be like Johnson & Johnson when the
tampering took place on Tylenol you need
to sit there and recognize that you
didn't cause this to happen but it's
your responsibility because it's your
product they know no they don't and it's
too bad because I mean I want to help
and others want to help I think the
issue my partner trust on Harris and
Renee direst and the rest of our team
we're sitting there saying listen this
is a crisis the government of Myanmar is
using this product to make the genocide
of Roe hanga acceptable in Myanmar there
are these horrible things going on and
I'm sitting there going guys you need to
you need to fix the product you need to
change the way the algorithms work you
need to change the business model but
there's a good outcome here we can make
this better than it is today you want to
talk to them they talk to us a facebook
spokesman told us in response to your
article quote we've made major progress
in combating false news fighting
harassment bringing more transparency in
transparency to advertising and stopping
bad actors from meddling in foreign
elections we know we have more to do and
we will put our heads down and do the
work you've been talking about outside
actors what about inside Facebook what
they use to make money to capture people
how much of that is part of what you're
describing it is it's
actly the problem that essentially the
very tools it's the Russians didn't do
they didn't hack the system they didn't
do something special they did exactly
what advertisers are supposed to do and
the really important thing to understand
is advertising is a small part of the
problem it's Facebook groups it's this
notion that in facebook what they really
want do is appeal to fear and anger
because those are the things that
motivate you they engage you that get
you really focused on the kind of I'm
sure how to solve the problem as you see
it so I think the most important thing
we have to focus on today is children
and my dear friend Jim Steyer at Common
Sense Media he gives me the rules of
thumb for parents right the most
important thing is you have to be a good
role model if you're using your phone 24
hours a day if you're using it you know
your there's your children are gonna
pick up on that you have to be their
best teacher you have to set clear
limits right as what is the appropriate
usage of these products and then they
have a thing called device free dinner
where they're trying to say to people
listen have this meal where the whole
family's together and you actually talk
to each other and I'd say if you're an
adult all those rules apply as well they
set limits honestly don't let turn off
your notifications right don't let this
thing control your life really
interesting I could talk to you for a
long time well I don't come back this
issue is not going to be solved quickly
and we're gonna have to work together
and thank you so much for giving us a
chance because I really think we think
you should go try to talk to Cheryl and
mark I would like you stop talking but
keep reaching out to them all right
thank you thank you for her thank you
very much Roger it McNamee we're glad
you came today